if you are hoping to get your hands on
the gwent beta next month I have some
bad news for you previously expected to
begin in September CD Projekt RED
announced today that it is now coming at
the end of October in a statement the
developer said it needed some extra time
before letting the public pledge CD
Projekt RED said we know he can make a
first impression only once and we want
to make sure everything is ready before
we blast off delivering a good game is
more important to us than keeping a
deadline the developer added that it
understands delays can be disappointing
and apologize for making fans wait a
little bit longer the closed beta is now
scheduled to begin on October 25th
Gwen's closed beta is being held on xbox
one and pc though the full game is also
coming to PlayStation 4 you can sign up
for the beta on the gwent website though
there is no guarantee you'll get in
gamespot plague when at e3 where the
game was announced and discovered that
it's more like The Witcher 3 than you
think the collectible card game has a 10
plus our campaign voice acting in an
open world additionally CD Projekt RED
is hopeful the game will eventually
support xbox one ps4 cross-play for more
on The Witcher and quent stay tuned to
gamespot